are the Spice Girls coming back come on
well Geri Halliwell
Emma Bunton and the Mel B released this
new video with the message we hope to
tell you soon but hold up because that
we probably won't include posh or sporty
spice the videos from the YouTube
channel Spice Girls gym and now think
about the gym GE M standing for Gerry
Emma and Mel oxy and I see but I need
all five of them that's what I'm saying
yes because today actually marks the
20th anniversary of the hip wanna be in
some of the ladies clothes and birthday
hats to celebrate and because this is
flashback Friday can we know what you
want what you really really well come on
now you didn't I try we're giving you
guys with 18 Spice Girls rewind 20 years
ago what we all wanted was to be a Spice
Girl whether you fancied yourself scary
sporty posh baby or ginger do you have a
favorite Spice Girl I like Scary Spice
why babies place from the then
eleven-year-old Olsen twins to 15 year
old fan Prince William and 13 year old
Prince Harry
their breakout song wanna be hit number
one in 37 countries and sold more than 7
million copies worldwide think we wrote
it may been about 15-20 minutes how are
you guys feeling now with all this hog
maws Spice Girls you know you guys are
right we're on that bus run driving I
want one of Main Street the tall
building we saw that et was with the
band just after the release of their
debut album spice and got a private
acapella serenade one of these girls is
doing their own thing one of these girls
just any time any day
anyway anyway girl power became their
calling card while they had five
different personalities they had one
very strong female bond we are five best
friends here and we are in Hollywood
doing a premiere at a movie we are like
the Spice Girls stood for feminism and
female friendships paving the way for
women in music today
yep like the queen of squad goals
herself as well as new girl bands like
fifth harmony who even covered the Spice
Girls
20 years later wannabe has 94 million
streams on Spotify the girls still get
together posting pics on Instagram and
their message of empowerment still lives
on come on you know you guys still love
that song and it get you going doesn't
it
well Mel C is now focusing on a solo
album Pasha's focused of course on her
fashion line and that trio calling
themselves Jim well those ladies have
reportedly agreed to do a one-off
concert in London this time next year